hello welcome to our new and Wolfram
language 12 webinar series today is the
fourth and final session in our webinar
series that has covered significant
areas of new and expanded functionality
and Neph matica and the Wolfram language
my name is Jaime Peterson I'm the
technical programs manager for Wolfram
you a free and open learning hub that
features interactive courses video
classes and webinars like this one thank
you for joining us today
today you'll be learning about the
latest Wolfram language functionality
for integrating with external languages
interfacing with real world systems
interacting with blockchains and
compiling and optimizing code with the
new Wolfram compiler presenting for us
today our Tod Gailey director of engine
and connectivity engineering Suba thomas
software engineer Charles Poe manager of
discrete computation Christian Pascal
connectivity manager for Wolfram
research South America and Abdul de Kock
senior compiler developer so before we
get started with this very exciting and
broad list of presentations I'm gonna go
ahead and push a pull out that should be
showing up on your screen this asks you
about your level of experience with
Mathematica and the Wolfram language yep
okay so 70% of you are currently using
the Wolfram language and that's great
that's kind of what we expected but we
do have about 9% brand new and others
that have not recently used so this is
great we're anxious to show you all the
version 12 functionality today let's put
another poll out this one asks about the
version that you're using and many of
you hopefully are already using version
12 that was released just a few weeks
ago as we started this webinar series
if each new version of Mathematica and
the Wolfram language includes new and
expanding functionality front end
enhancements and system-wide performance
improvements so it's good to know from
what point you're arriving at when you
see this version 12 functionality today
almost 70 percent are using version 12
the very latest version but some some
stragglers with some older
versions and that's fine too hopefully
we'll be giving you some good
information that you can use today okay
that's all the information I needed to
share I think I'm ready to pass the
microphone and the screen - Todd Gailey
now who's going to get us started with
external system integration
all right hello everyone
my name is ty Gailey and I'm the
director of engine and connectivity
engineering at Wolfram I'll be talking
today about features in version 12 of
the Wolfram language that involves
connectivity to other languages and
environments although this is a new in
12 webinar some of the things I'll be
talking about are not actually brand new
in 12 present 11.3 marked as
experimental in many cases still marked
as experiment by the way so still quite
new to the Wolfram world and we want to
make sure that people know about their
existence that you can make the best
possible use of them
there are some things some changes and
new features for version 12 and I will
point those out as it go there also some
new things coming in a future which I'll
mentioned as well
well firm has always recognized the
importance of the connectivity to other
languages we were an early innovator in
this field with the development of
j-link
integration with Java now coming up on
its 20th anniversary follow that up with
net link for Microsoft Annette lash
those links provide an extremely tight
integration with their respective
languages effectively making the Wolfram
language a scripting language for Java
and diners of course the world of
computing changes rapidly new languages
rise and become important very quickly
very many popular languages now and some
are especially important in certain
niches
we now think that the best way to
support a variety of languages is with
the general framework that perhaps does
not provide quite as tight an
integration with the target language
because most users what they need to
interoperate the way they want that is
the external evaluator work
so one of the nicest features of the
external diary train work is the
so-called external language cells you
just and open a notebook and hit the
right arrow as the first character and
sell the automatically converts to an
external language
the default is Python cell which you can
tell from this will take on logo there
on that on the left so I can just type
some arbitrary Python code in this cell
just as if I was typing at a Python
prompt of course I knows how to evaluate
to question so I mean this is a trivial
example but I want to minimize the
importance you now can you know you now
have a Python cell type that you type
arbitrary Python code arbitrary Python
computations into a notebook and
evaluate them and get results back
data types are converted in it we think
is the most natural way when sending to
Python or returning back to the Wolfram
language obviously that when I did two
plus two a minute ago and I got four
back that was the number four in Wolfram
language here I create
place on dictionaries and return it and
that comes back as an association in the
local language all of the standard types
that you might think are supported
numbers lists associations and
dictionaries are mapped here's a more
complicated example
I take an umpire array
numpy arrays come back as these numeric
array expressions your language now
numeric array is experimental function
in the Wolfram inversion 12 so you might
not know know about it this is just
about the only contain right now that
uses numeric array that exposes it but
we'll be exposing this more in the
future
efficient array representation we use
numeric array
because
we might expect these Python numpy
arrays with these large which a normal
of
each person to a regular list
and here's an example where I uses
pandas it's a popular data science
library
I created data frame
and you know this is really it now I
guess the data fam is very much
analogous to a Wolfram language data set
so that is what it gets converted to
automatically Wolfram language gates of
course the reverse would happen as well
if I have a Python function that took a
Candice data frame and I could pass it a
data set from the Wolfram language it
would all turn out to be converted
it's not a feature so it's very very
convenient and handy to have a cell type
you just type code in just like it's
just like you're typing in your favorite
editor for that language there's another
way which is the external evaluator
function which is more convenient if
you're trying to write a program if
you're integrating Python code into
wassail language programs
so here I just type external evaluate I
give this system name Python and then I
just a string of Python code this is
effectively like four by calling two
expression on most language code
evaluate that so I'm just you doing some
you know cumulative something and using
some numpy functions I know if I this
print
I printed from Python and it comes back
I think I'll put it in in the Wolfram
language so it's quite convenient Finch
I read across and I get back in numeric
array
so if I wanted to use this in a program
or a tribute leave through I'm just
going to say want to transpose it so
here's just a combined program where I'm
using local language functionality
wrapping around a call for Python then
there's my transposed array
I'm sure
some troubleshooting
if you try external evaluate or external
language cell it doesn't work to get
some message about complaining about
maybe some missing dependencies or some
other thing about motor failure it's
likely that either simply don't have the
appropriate language installed or it's
missing a required dependency there's
this find external evaluator it's
function which you can use you give it
the name of the system you want in and
that's what it returns for my system as
you can see I don't even know why I have
so many copies of Python installed in my
system but we know how to go out and
find them and so this is all the sort of
external libraries I have and you notice
in this one it says missing dependencies
it's virtually certain if you have
pythons or no js' or one of the other
languages are supported if you have this
installing system and works on the
command line but it doesn't work with
external evaluation and it's very likely
that it's missing the zero in acute
library we require 0 mq as the that's
the communications mechanism between
from n these other languages many
languages don't come by default with
Israel and to line ranges all so it's
very likely if that's the fact that it's
not working but you have the language
that you don't have the zoo and cue
library for it so that's the number one
thing to try to install you can also say
there's also a register external
evaluator function so for example in
this list when I do a python cell
gee
first listed Python evaluated this which
is going to going to get used I might
want a different one so if I wanted save
my Python 2.6 or this to plot 2.7
example is for this one if I wanted this
one this place on three one to be used
instead
and I simply call a register external
evaluator that will push it to the I
mean it's already my sister already
knows about this but if I just call this
function it brings it to the top so if I
call this and then to another Python
cell and that evaluation will go to this
evaluator
and we have documentation pages for
configuring Python and configuring
nodejs here's the problem third window
here's the page they took trouble
troubleshooting page for configuring
nodejs and strategy and this is exactly
what I had to do and I tried this nodejs
for the first time then didn't work it
was precisely because of this missing
zero and few dependency I just went
through these steps and then everything
so we do have documentation to this
workflows for fixing these problems
right
but we could have a new in 12 functions
part of this framework it's called
external function start a function it's
a Wolfram language function whose
implementation is in an external
language it's like a handle to a
function that's implemented in the
external language
so in this example this is no js'
pushover - no js' for a moment if you
click on this icon you wonder what you
want might wonder how do I get in no JSL
well you can click on this icon so these
external language cells in one of the
supported evaluators just click no js'
so here's an ojf function
valuation is smart enough to know that
it was a function that was returned it's
evaluated to a function so it returns
this external function expression
kernel function you know if you look at
it you could open it up just for sake
has also its information about it shows
their what type of function is it
actually shows the source code
this shows the accession that
dysfunction is defined it so I can you
know I can simply I'll call that F
and then if I just can call F and I'll
get the result so effectively defined a
Wolfram language function of F whose
implementation resides in so J is pretty
cool
you can also create an external function
directly you can just type it in in a
previous example I just I used a no GS
cell because when I evaluate that nodejs
cell the result of the evaluation was
function definition I automatically got
an external function object back in both
language but I can also just type
external function indirectly
just in line the source code
make it function I named it curtain day
- just call it
this is a more convenient programmatic
way to create functions
if you feel a little careful with
session management and this is something
of a tricky aspect of external
evaluating these external language cells
and we at the moment we don't have a
great system for for doing this type of
management we're going to change some
things around and add some features to
this but for now you have to have to be
aware of some issues so here I'm going
to manually create an external function
this is just built in function land in
Python and if I call it my list of
course it can sir
try something else let's create if I
just call see here I called external
function I guess call external evaluate
Python LAN I get an external function
back as well so you think okay that's
great it worked fine so that it was
smart enough to know that this was
functions or create external function
caller
but didn't work so what happened
the problem Spanish so we're going to
change this behavior but we have to know
it now is that when you call external
evaluate when I make this call
PACA creates a Python session starts one
fresh and kills it at the end
it's a one-shot thing start will
evaluate is a one-shot thing doesn't use
the same Python evaluator used by Python
cells so if I build up a bunch of state
in Python so Python cells and I call you
know like some function definition
something I call external evaluate and
you know Python comma and then try to
call some of those functions if you
won't work because it's starting up a
fresh session it's not the same session
in which those functions were defined
so that's what happened here as soon as
this external guy wood ended in this
some functionality is returned that
Python session was exited I call it this
this message tells me that this session
object is not even valid anymore so
there's a simple solution to this and
just simply to always do direct session
management I say there's a function
called start external session so now I
have a handle to a persistent session
and I can use this instead of using
instead of using this you know magic
string
Python as first are going to excited I
used in this obsession reference now I'm
just
make that definition in this session and
now it works so the important thing is
that I created a long-lived accession
called you know with explicit name and I
use that lets quite convenient to just
say external evaluate of you know Python
as a string law but
the Python says to be closed when that
external guy always finishes but if you
really wanted to persist create create a
session manually and use that as the
first argument now we you're probably
thinking that's add that's a dumb idea
that's bad behavior for that plate on
session to exit I agree
definitely going to change that so it's
some plan in the future probably very
immediate future that will change so
that I will not immediately exit the
session just run but but for now it does
so so be aware of that think I have one
more same thing I can also make here I
make my own definition of it some
trivial Python function and then return
it and get an external function
expression this is just an example of a
function inlining a function definition
we do have more languages coming
essentially any language that has a
repla read eval print loop can be
supported in the external diary
frameworks we already have Ruby Julie
ago Haskell in the works Java has a
ripple now to do this for Java and other
languages in fact we'll probably
document how to do it because well
within the capabilities of a interested
programmer to create one of these
external evaluate no plugins in effect
for their favorite language
all right another feature that's new or
change in version 12 it is for web
browser control and it's just kind of a
niche thing perhaps for many people but
it's really quite handy in version 11
point 3 you could do this I'm not gonna
die with this up cause it doesn't work
anymore
you could use external violet with this
you know webdriver - Chrome with our
magic environment and and you know pass
some sort of relatively obscure set of
arguments - to capture a webpage that
capability has been eliminated
it's reflect by a simpler much more
direct interface with browser control so
now I can just say web image give the
URL I'm going to in fact I'm going to
run this
I don't know you probably didn't see it
didn't pop up on this screen when you
run this the web browser launches in it
goes through whatever scripting
operations are in the background and
finishes so
selling compare web image to this
obscure mad line
you can do much more complex things the
main function is called web execute you
know you say you start a web session and
you call web executing and they're Docs
or WebEx execute long and there's a huge
number of these little keys that you can
use to do also suspect you can script
button presses and form page submissions
and all sorts of things you can
essentially script an arbitrary user
interaction with the web browser
quite handy for web testing or something
like that web scraping in this example
I'm just going to open a Wikipedia page
and abstract all the hyperlinks page
in the background web browser launches
and then here's this short shortened
blighted result of 81 different
hyperlink
and then finally I want to mention the
Wolfram client library for Python
extremely handy powerful library new
library makes it very easy to access
Wolfram language functionality from
Python now this is not strictly a
feature of version 12 it works in other
versions of other versions of the
Wolfram language but it's out its new
now now for a little while but it's
still quite new it's open source fully
documented find it on github but you
don't have to do anything you don't have
to go make it or something off github
you can just say tip install will from
clients in kit
not we're going to show an example to
dish
some things you can do you can evaluate
expressions or local wolfram Colonel
Cloud or Enterprise Wolfram cloud so
it's quite handy you can direct your
computations either local criminal or a
cloud colonel
without really changing your code in any
way you can call Wolfram cloud API
convenient interface for calling Wolfram
cloud EAP is represent arbitrary Wolfram
language expressions and programs in
pipe very simple syntax I wish Jaden
could have something as slick as that
but it's not Python for prep sending
Wolfram language expressions you can
call built-in Wolfram language functions
directly in Python
you can easily define native Python
functions or call water management is
all sorts of good documentation showing
all these features there's a link to the
library documentation
you
you
here's you know lovely examples of all
these different types of functionalities
it's very simple to use
it's linked to a blog post announcing it
has mother other examples of its usage
here's a link to get a home page there
are other client libraries to follow
there's a Java one that is just
polishing up now
all right I think that is that is the
end of my presentation so I'd like it
pass it along now Shuba who will be
talking about the microcontroller kit
thank you
thanks Todd um so as Todd mentioned I'll
be talking about the microcontroller kit
which is new in version 12 so let me
first spell out the outline for this
presentation it has three parts
I will start with an overview of the of
how the microcontroller kit operates and
what you need to get it up and running
next I will demo some building blocks
using concrete examples and finally I
will demo a sample project so what I
wish to convey si with the stock as I
drill down from a 10,000 foot view to
examples and then a sample project is
that the microcontroller kit is on one
hand a very straightforward of r2 but on
the other hand it's also very versatile
and powerful because essentially there
is only one function that you will be
using to deploy code to the various
microcontrollers so once you have what
you want the microcontroller to do you
just have a uniform paradigm and you're
specifying the code you want to deploy
deploy at a very high level so it's the
same paradigm that's repeated over and
over again for the various
microcontrollers and also the various
computations you want to do on the
microcontroller so this is the workflow
of the of the microcontroller kit so
it's a three-stage process so it first
generates the source code and and then
it invokes a compiler to compile this
code and then it uploads that compiled
code through using a programmer through
an external programmer to the
microcontroller so the setup you need
for that flows from this workflow so of
course you need the Wolfram language and
the microcontroller kit so I'm going to
first
load the microcontroller kit and then
you need a compiler so the most
straightforward solution is to is to
install the arduino ide so i have
already have the arduino ide arduino
installed on my machine and it's a Mac
so I just make sure that it exists so
well what others even if you're on a Mac
or if even if you're on a Windows or
Linux system you just have to install
the arduino ide and the microcontroller
kit will pick up the compiler tool chain
yeah in case you have a custom compiler
tool chain or asses in some other
location it's just an option just to
tell microcontroller kit where to find
the compiler so as i mentioned there is
only one function that you used to to
upload the code and that is
microcontroller embed code and it has
three arguments so the this fourth
argument is is an assortment of optional
specifications so there so all if you
have a custom compiler installation this
is where you will specify that and we'll
also see some examples where we use
these additional specifications but
essentially there are mostly there are
three specifications that the
microcontroller embed code takes the
first one is the systems model or the
core computation that the
microcontroller needs to do so i'd like
to think of this as what is the
computation you want the microcontroller
to do and the second argument has to do
with the microcontroller itself so it
answers questions like which
microcontroller do you want to send the
computation through which inputs do you
want to use which outputs and other
microcontroller specifications and the
third one is where is this
microcontroller located so this may be
like a connection port or to which the
microcontroller is connected to your to
your PC and
this is the mechanism to get the
compiled code on on to the
microcontroller so so let's start
looking at some examples so this is the
simple simplest example I want to blink
an LED so the first argument is the
system's model and I want to blink an
LED connected to pin 3 so I'm going to
I'm going to connect that elidio right
now so I connect the one end of the
resistor to ground and the other one to
pin 3 okay so I have this this set up
here and now this is the computation I
want to do if that the level of that pin
is above zero I turn it to zero and if
and if it is zero I turn it on it's
basically a pulse and then so that's the
first argument in the second argument I
say that my target is and if the target
is an Arduino Uno and the output I'm
using is output three and it's a digital
output and this is the port to which
this microcontroller is connected to my
Mac so now if I evaluate that
what happened should work if all the
connections are right
I think I have my ground sorry about
that had my ground pin corrected in
color connected incorrectly but now you
should see the LED blinky and it
returned this microcontroller code data
object from which I can get additional
properties so I can take this object and
then ask for properties and it will have
a whole slew of properties and from this
I can get what was the source code and
so on
so let's modify this just a little bit
so instead of turning this LED on and
off I want to send an analog output that
is it's the level the value that is sent
to the LED is continuously varying from
0 to 5 volts so in this case the and and
I'm adjusting that value using a
potentiometer so let's let me connect
the potentiometer and hopefully this
time I don't mix up my pins I connect
one end of the potentiometer to ground
the other the other end to 5 volts and
the WIPO pin to 0 now the value of the
value that the potentiometer reads I
want to send directly to the LED so the
systems model is just a unity gain of 1
and and now my target is again Arduino
Uno the input is from the analog pin a 0
it's an analog input and the output is
again digital pin 3 but instead of being
a digital output as it is outputting now
I want it to be an analog output and
then I'm going to evaluate this and now
ok once it's done if I adjust this you
can see the LED I don't know how clear
it is with the lighting in this room but
you should see the LED
increase in brightness and be turned off
so I'm going to do a little more
involved example so here I have an
Adafruit metro let me let me get that
set about
so so here I have an Adafruit Metro that
is is connected to a Mac 66 sound for a
temperature sensor and I want and this
is a temperature sensor and I want to
output the the result onto an LCD
through a backpack so the input is just
simply passed it simply passed to the
output so so as before I have a unity
gain one now we're here this is an SPI
input so as before it's not just one
input to which one pin through which the
input is coming in so because this is an
SPI device the the input is coming in
through pin 12 which is master input
slave output pin so this device is a
slave and through its slave output pin
it's sending the output to pin 12 that's
why I have the input chant the input is
coming through pin 12 and it's of type
SPI now this microcontroller needs to
request that data from this from this
device and to do that it needs to set
the slave output pin of this device to
the chip selects pin of this device to
true to be low so the slave output pin
is the pin through which the output is
sent and the chip select pin is what
needs to be set low by the
microcontroller for this device to start
sending the result so I've chosen pin 7
as the pin to trigger the to start the
device to send start sending output so
once ambit might let me evaluate these
so once microcontroller embed code sees
this it it knows that it needs to
configure this microcontroller itself as
a master spi device and once it does
that it sets pin 13 as the clock pin
that is that's fixed from the dear she
there's the clock pin and I connect that
pin to
clock of the of the sensor and the other
two connections are the ground bender
and the five volt power lines okay so
but that that is not the end of the
story so once that is set up the
microcontroller also needs to know how
many bytes to request from the from the
device and what to do with what to do
with that and this comes from the
datasheet of the of the sensor the data
comes in as two bytes so I'm going to
give the specification of that device as
the slave select pin 7 and it has to
read in 2 bytes it's going to select
that let us bring that pin low and then
it's going to read 2 bytes and then it's
going to use that 2 bytes to compute the
to compute the temperature using this
incantation yeah this information all
comes from the from the datasheet
so to summarize for the input channel
the data is coming in through pin 12 it
comes in when the microcontroller sets
this pin this chip select pin low chip
select pin low and then the
microcontroller computes the the reads
in two bytes and computes the
temperature using this using this code
so that's all for the input Channel now
the output yeah the output I have
connected through this Adafruit LCD
BacPac and it uses I squared C
communication so I squared C is in the
specification is somewhat similar to SPI
but I decided to use the library that is
provided by Adafruit so when we use the
library so first thing we need to do is
install the libraries so that's the
standard way you install it for for any
install any Arduino library so I've
already installed it and it's exist and
when we when we are using the library we
do not really understand
we know the I squared C specification
but we need to understand the library
and and well and this is the only time
when you'll be writing X explicit code
because you have to inject that code in
the code that is being automatically
generated by microcontroller embed code
so this is the generals program layout
and this library code has to be injected
into various segments of this of this
program so to get this get this LCD to
LCD BacPac to send the the values to
this LCD we need to include these these
header files one is the I square wire
header file and then is the header file
for the link for their liquid crystal
display itself and then this is the
where we create the object and then we
begin to initialize that LCD it's a 16
character LCD with two rows of values I
said the backlight to be high I set the
cursor to location 2 that is the second
character in line 0 and I print the
value temperature so this when when when
when I send this program this is what is
going to first happen and then in a loop
what needs to happen is the actual
output Channel so this is of type
external library and then I'm telling
what the microcontroller needs to run in
a loop it the value that it receives its
assigns to the well to the variable temp
it sets the cursor to position 4 and in
line 1 so that is over there it and it
prints that value and this is printing
degree centigrade so all this the input
outputs and everything we need and all
the utilities and initialization is that
gives the complete microcontroller
specification and now I'm ready to
deploy the code so here is where I use
the fourth argument so this is the
fourth argument and the fourth argument
I need to specify where it can find the
library and also the details about the
SPI device so if I evaluate that
it's kind little warm in this room but I
have a cup of ice here and if I dip it
in should see the temperature drop I
have a nice cup so now let's look at a
sample project so I here I have let me
get that motor out
yeah so my objective is to deploy a
controller to regulate the speed of this
motor so yeah for this talk I'm not
going to go how I obtained the
controller so you can find more details
on that in the documentation but this is
a but the controller has two inputs so
the first input is coming from this
potentiometer here that I have connected
to pin 2 and that is sent setting the
reference speed that the motor needs to
run it yeah let me get the controller so
the first input is the analog input that
the motor needs to that that gives the
reference speed of the that I need the
motor to turn and then this the second
input is the actual speed of the motor
and that is coming through an encoder
which I have connected to pin 2 so this
is a series of pulses so the more number
of pulses implies that the motor is
going faster and we can count the number
of pulses by counting the rising edges
or the falling edges or even the number
of times it's toggling I've chosen to
count the number of rising edges so this
is a very high-level specification we
just say we need to count the number of
rising edges and that will tablet that
we convert using this block here to the
speed of the motor in rpm so that is the
inputs and in and the output it's an
analog output that is being sent to the
yes so this goes through the motor
shield and that is what is sending the
speed it's an analog signal just like
it's the same thing as the when I was
adjusting the brightness of the LED it's
exactly the same thing except that over
there it went from 0 to 5 volts or 5
volts filled up the register with the
value 255 but over here I
max values hundred that's the duty cycle
the motor has to run it so at that value
the motor will go at full speed or that
register will be full so it's an
additional option we give and then I
have two additional outputs here because
I want to actually bring it bring the
speeds back into Mathematica and be able
to visualize it so so again if you see
the paradigm it's the kind of
computation we want to do the input
channels and the output channels and
then should be - let me evaluate it so
now if I pull you can see the motor
going faster as I pick it up and now I
would like to wish you like an see that
the motor is is responding to my thing
and even if I give some disturbance you
can see it's resisting the disturbance
and trying to maintain the speed but I
would like to actually see what these
actual values are and that's that's my
motivation for having these two serial
outputs so I can bring them back into
Mathematica but you can connect any
serial application to it you can connect
either screen or even the arduino ide to
see those values but here I have used
the device framework in Mathematica so
so I'm going to open a connection to
that to that port and I'm going to start
reading the value so let me set it to
some value so how the data is coming in
as there is a start byte then there's a
delimiter and there's an end byte and
that is like the data in in one sampling
period of of the controller so I so this
has both the reference speed and also
the actual speed and there is a
delimiter byte size so I I split it and
I get the two values and this this is
coming in ASCII codes let me flush it it
should not be zero
yeah so this is the current speed at
which the motor is turning let me
increase the speed a little bit
see you see I get the so I'm going to
put this these these functions of
reading it and you know this function of
actually splitting this data that's
coming in and and converting that ascii
codes to two expressions in this
function pasta dice I split it and then
I create an expression so now once I
have this function I can just read the
data I'm going to read I'm going to read
the data and just and then parse it and
so I should have a second I can
dynamically see as I decrease the speed
I can see the speed going down and as I
increase it I can see see it going up
but this is not exactly what I want to
do so I also like to actually visualize
it so what I do is I create a scheduled
task with the same thing I if if the
serial data is ready I I have the same
code where I parse the incoming data and
append it to this variable Y and if I
run this now the speed of the data the
speed of the motor is being appended to
this value to this variable Y and now I
can start plotting it so this is the
speed and if you can see the reference
and after some time the actual speed of
the model see I can I can give it some
disturbance and see how the if I take it
off so let me turn this off
and then finally I will remove the tasks
and close the device okay just to
summarize so the kit is based on just
one super function microcontroller embed
code it provides a very unified in
interface or whatever the
microcontroller be whatever the inputs
end up and the output channel you want
to use it's just this one function that
you will be using the three arguments
are systems model of what you want the
microcontroller to compute the
microcontroller specifications which
microcontroller which inputs which
outputs and how they should be
configured and the upload mechanism or
where is the microcontroller and how we
get the code to that and it returns a
microcontroller code data object that
can be used to obtain the source code
and other properties so if you want to
see what what are the targets that we
support we have some entity types
microcontroller target so that will the
entire list will give you what are the
microcontrollers that we support what
from which vendors they are and these
are the families that we currently
support so the so I have not been able
to cover all the input/output
configurations but we have extensive
documentation in in in the guide page
and also in the new in 12 page so I
would encourage you to go and and take a
look at those so for me personally it
has been a great experience working
developing this kit it's it's all the
more rewarding when these things
actually work and I hope you find this
functionality useful for your projects
as well right with that I think I'll
wrap up my part of the talk and I'm
going to hand it over to Charles we'll
be talking about about the unity link
Thank You subha I'm going to actually
present our unit early which was
introduced in version 4 and gun
well what's unit elated unity link is
essentially a building package it
provided for Schneider 20 gradually till
on the Wolfram language the validation
data sharing and essentially from unity
we can call one language nationality of
community so why is it actually you know
useful and quite a blessing to do that
first unit is a game of a game engine
so essentially you know also the studio
most of the packages in unity engine but
from the one side you know if you look
at unity it can provide you for example
the physic engine because you need to
actually ship with physics develop at
Nvidia so you can actually from the
Wolfram language physical physique X or
you can actually also use the high
quality hand we know all the real-time
boundary you actually have a unity and
also you need to have a whole lot of
acid unlit utility in the acid storm can
actually use a little actually I will
show how you can actually turn to those
phosphates and violent language now for
the whole family
I mean from the unity side what will you
use the Wolfram language whooping
language actually a very powerful
scripting environment and it's actually
unique one where you can actually open a
notebook on coffee speaking you know why
the confessional acid or meet you know
the future hold the bat we can see how
things work onto the tablet I don't
actually have to no worries really start
with you know shisha and all the
detailing
no audible programming massage but also
the Wolfram language come obviously with
all the we don't know for family pays
you know the greater data you know image
processing would you processing Joe you
know Joe John geometric computer
we have in place so you can actually tap
on those language we on this one
straight to the work on language and use
them in unity so if you want to create a
message you can actually reach it no
word on language and move it to you but
also as you can imagine you know the
Wolfram language have a lot of
functionality in term of analytic as
well as a whole suite of technology you
can actually use a multi that
abstraction push a data or to use
Wolfram cloud to interact to it yeah so
let's first start in a practical way
first what you need to use what you need
first to have in your machine let's
assume you are on the desktop so that
you can use unity you need for the
Wolfram language or the Wacom engine so
you can download the full form engine
which is actually currently before the
group or you can have Mathematica and
when you have them installed and you
also install unity Nomi automatically
detect unity and try to establish the
connection and later on I will actually
show you documentation in case where you
have renewal issues the windows set home
you can actually look at all the details
so let's do that actually more
concretely so here actually I mean did
you know in notebook so I can load the
unity link by just evaluating needs
unity link so new technique is
automatically loaded in this case and I
can actually do a actually hub so unity
actually is starting and you can see it
on the right corner there essentially
it's loading say take a wife for unity
to start the project but at the same
time you are actually javi itself that
would actually show the progress
essentially that we are opting unity so
in this case we have an example which is
already embedded in the world from
language we have a set of sample
projects which can help you actually to
start on unity community
so in this case take a little longer to
start so he's almost there and as soon
as unity start on open will get actually
unity there especially so what actually
happened behind the scene is that we
look in on unity but at the same time
you know we established that optional
connections between England the Unity
engine and that tried the work on and
jam behind you see - that is actually
approaching the package on the component
so you see that you know here you have
unique tradition already launched and it
works on them they're out in circle each
dot and you can you know one of your
thing you can do is you can ask you know
can you find me the game object ball
with this seem so you have this seemed a
and then you how to build the board so
that's kind of the first out you know
income automatically you know connect an
open project unity project from the
world home language so let's start on
look a little bit about the inertia of
unity object and that's actually kind of
mine but actually quite easy to see how
you design you do that symbolic language
object so first immunity you have the be
seen that's kind of the fundamental part
of everything is possible it's a 3d
environment where you know every gene is
the doulton exists inside this thing you
have the game object so the chem
objectors check the most important
objective unity so like if you look at
the game you have a player essentially
the game object all you have you know
others part of the the game essentially
remained active part in the image
relationship became object to the game
object can essentially have you know
john mccain in collision detection or
easy on the bottom
party can attach to it so the Wolfram
language what we do essentially which
actually stated on their first for a
scene we returned in unity scene object
which is actually attached to that
object in unity and forgive me off
gently returning into game object
example and for component which are part
of a game object we also introduced a
symbolic representation of this
component in this case unit as form
which is kind of one absorb the
fundamental object future component
which always come with the game object
and any other component for example in
mesh we have unity mesh you have a light
emitting light and Canada so all those
are components attached to your game
object and the last part essentially
also are the assets you can think about
it as you know a specific file you don't
stop on your harddrive so those also
present those assets and you can take
you know image for example arm generator
and a set of it on you store it in your
harddrive and I will show some example
right now
so let's actually first switch what I
will do I mean from this original sin a
virtual is just create a new scene and
in that scene are actually going to put
a keyboard so if I click on it so I have
my new scene called my scene and they
have a cuboid a call of a Joe from from
that cube already essentially I mean
from that scene I can add the light so
if you click on it you see that you have
a light there and I can create a mesh on
the side to actually save it as an asset
or generate an asset of it and you see
that here I have a university called
duty quality the old a set of
functionality so this was essentially
the main constructor how you can create
object so now the next is how can you
find the object you also introduced you
know function like find unity scene will
return you the actual handle orders and
presentation of this currency and you
can take essentially data object on for
example acts property so that we will
tell you the property of the object and
you know for example if proper channel
ax was the name of my seen anything it
is my C which is kind of on in there
so this is you know how to find this in
they also have we also have find unity
game object which also find the game
objects in your currency so in this case
there is a game object called main
camera and also that one you can also
get all the properties quite easily the
transfer massage and in this case
actually if you ask a person like
transform which is actually component
you actually will turn with the
responded component so you actually have
that handle so if I click on mean camera
here you have that transform component
and again you can access to position was
the rotation so you actually have the
direct control of the unity editor on
what's actually happening and you
actually can modify that in place and we
have the same in terms of unity
component and demo finding unity assets
so from the constructor and the search
function we also have the destructor we
can essentially take it and destroy it
they store the object or the asset so in
this case left for example who moved to
decade one asset so I can just evaluate
this and voila meteorite one asset is
gone from the scene okay
so we introduced our Charlie etcetera
also we have the constructor and then we
have a function to find or search those
element opponent object community and
harvest doctor but one language we try
to there's no high level functionality
committed more generally
as well as we try to include you know
existing functionality in the system so
in this case I'm going to just show you
how we actually did integration with our
visitation functions action function
essentially you can take a plot in this
case I generate a revolution plot which
is a Catholic so I have an object there
and then a Jody said that I wanted
immunity so I can't just evaluate it and
they call it my plot and they'd say okay
I want to create a game object out of it
so what we do behind the scenes that we
take that object you recognize that is a
mesh it can be transformed to a mesh see
the geometry so we are going to create a
game object and then add the mesh
component to it so in this case let me
first move the edge on here so there you
have the that object in unity so it has
the geometry and you have all the
property and if I click there you have
the mesh and then you have you know all
the nice property on bacteria we try to
kind of kill or try to preserve you know
the loop or a shadow you have the word
on language on to push the material
because only material will decide so you
can also essentially type in all our you
know knowledge base where you have to
protect you know 3d object from
anatomical structure to know real world
Portugal topographic data are events you
can decide for example you know I want
to you know get you know information
about the more whatever I said ecology
and then you can generate it and then
you can take that they turned in you
know with a click push it to minute you
actually have air or data sorry
move there and it's actually pushing it
to unity and then I have this call here
for the middle of the treatment is there
I can just rotate it on here and I have
this code in your case for example unity
no actually have all the support of a
and B are you know if you have just you
know your di device connected to your
machine actually see that object
quite easy so that's kind of that aspect
that powerful aspect of the word on
language or you can actually create
contain especially in the comic
automatical way from no word from code
and push it to unity and that's kind of
pivot amidst any object when I will not
evaluate here well this is an example of
reducers you know this kind of also an
aspect well you can just take search on
the web using our web would you search
in Hindu audio manipulated anything you
need and here you do it to it you know
bility audio t which does that
automatically so this kind of show you
that high level integration where you
can actually take you know information
from Wolfram language and your
traumatically movie to units under the
white mapping we will do the white
object okay so what we try to do in the
remaining time is just to show you an
object example we have in the
documentation and actually let me first
come back here and just for the sake of
simplicity I will close unity actually I
should do it for our own clothes unity
just to close unity so how this is a
bi-directional in so we know that we
have unity open so we close it so what I
will do here I will actually open our
documentation and I will look for in
Italy and that will be tension also we
have it on on the web so you can
actually access it if you don't have
rich stone so we try to actually fully
documented time v12 so to kind of
preserve that you know Montague that
mental map I showed you from the scene
to the game object to the component and
asset and also what we try to do is to
show you the possible workflow from the
Wolfram language alikum call unity which
is actually what I did there but also we
provided class
unfortunately on the unity side where
you can just from the unity car the word
amlong
and without visa so you had that
directional lead between both as well as
you can also call the Wolfram language
or the wolf imagine on your desktop or
you know one businesses on the cloud or
in your chili would imagine which you
can actually connect to and at the
beginning here you actually see that we
have a set of you know sample project
but also some big page on information to
actually help you start with unity so
that is first the basic hard ability
work which is that mental map I showed
you earlier but also you can resolve
issue and see how to create game objects
on source so this kind of it would sauce
for you if you want to start to play
with the true and genomic unity and work
on language so let's see and go to this
concrete example which is the spiky so
in this example we are going to just
show you how you can do all free
speaking do the whole thing and the
whole animation from the world from
language that you can add in to avoid
censorship script and unity side so we
just moved that on the side and we just
start by evaluating on loading unit in E
which is already loaded I will create
here a project called spiky away so I do
it you need to append so it's too much
pal equality to unity on dislodging do I
say I'm establishing good connection
between the two engine so that's a take
a little bit time community to actually
start on and slowly waiting on
comparative in smugglers so but has unit
is opening next what we'll probably do
is then we're going to start to create
project we're going to create you know a
you know three I said directly once we
continue the scene while you continue
mesh another one will contain the
material just to kind of nicely
organized our project and as you know as
you see
this is kind of problematic so you can
actually do it and we start and we do
the project you don't have to be on
unity side and you know try to remember
what should be done socially and
actually document your project like I do
in this case done be able to produce it
so here I will create the unity I said
so if I come back down here like CBTs it
already to here material mesh thing and
by doing this additional assets I mean
what additional cities actually multi
package this is the unity package of
alternative package which actually allow
the connectivity between the unity asks
the you editor on both imagine currently
which to Tony so you have between a
project and at the end of your project
if you don't need it you can actually
delete it with Lloyd you don't really
need that connectivity an opportunity to
actually work with image editor okay so
now I'm going to create just a file is
simply you know it actually started a
zip file so is actually going to save it
and I will create a mesh which is
actually coming which is our spiky the
boundary mesh I'm using here period one
data for that and then I create a plane
so unity and platform and here we have
the property do know from the earlier
angle as well as to local scale for the
claim and now we are going to create you
know a bunch of spiky so in this case we
generates home handle position generate
some hand on color generic material out
of it so if you come back to unity here
so we have the symbolic representation
of the material here and if you compact
material the height will you see all of
them Speight you want to spiky 10 um now
I can take those meshes and then create
a game object so there are a bunch of
checked it could actually go ahead and
create a powerbomb them to the
corresponding team but in this case
which was create order sick of them was
a procedure just pretty much attract him
object and now from those game object
you can actually assign property so in
this case we take you know became object
and then you set up a position and also
we set up the material the scale and
also what we do is that well actually
some something more form you actually
add you know some physical physical
property tweets so here we actually add
collision detections so we create new
edges bodies and assign them to each
object with a mesh Collider to just make
the scene nice we delete the default
original image so then it's happening
now we actually create all the
additional light attached to it we
object so I will save the scene now I
can't on the Wolfram language
opportunity to plate so if I click there
so you need to behind the scenes
compiling and there we see so we have
that nice animation orbit from the
working language or you can actually
just in the Wolfram language on stop the
animation what you actually add even
more has a virtual function so what we
added is actually unity build so that
functional need to just you know in one
line compiler you again Harmon is
acquitted or so in this case it's
compiling you know despite a rain so I
pick you know take all the information
from the scene to the material and
assemble it appropriately and pass it to
unity actually generated under
successful mount if you open the summary
box tell you where the location of the
object
and in this case I just do system open
and I ask okay can you actually own that
so I get back information of spiky rain
and play and then I have actually a
standalone admission of my spike okay so
this is a nice example of how the
functionality from the world from
language language and actually you know
interact with unity so if I just go back
we also have an example in this case way
from the Wolfram language community we
can actually call the word from language
to our cloud epi so what I will suggest
you to go on quiet know just what after
the Box you evaluate it as long as you
have unity installed on the should be
able to actually play without the case
so what I want to point out you know
before I close this edition is that in a
real turning away from access to the
nationality and we try to deduct for
high-level function in the world from
language we provide you know somebody
representation of each object so that
you can actually have a full console
opportunity so that ain't good from the
c-sharp class we actually can open it
control schemes actually polygraph
interaction with you and also required
to make sure that you can easily
exchange data from unity the Wolfram
language and you can take advantage of
all the curated data on different
language to actually facility to our
development from a game to an animation
project you can actually want to build
but Maho by which you know what i will
not discuss in this case or not present
in this case your channel so although
you know you to tie directly to the
clouds you know non-shooting you back
home for example if you want generate
c-sharp code so that you can embed
embedded and called our word from our
cloud API for example and there was a
lot of more functionality so what we
suggest is you know go to our web page
you know the Wolfram language page you
know you get a lot of information there
I showed you a way to be really chilling
documentation and also what we hope in
the next future is we'll see a lot of
blogs like blogs and as well as
information from our community you can
actually see I shall project so which is
teaching both on community actually some
example on our our people use unity so
there is a lot of information for me to
start as well as a lot of dinner to play
okay so well
that's complete my presentation Abdul is
next and we will talk about the compiler
thank you so hello my name is Abdul and
I'm gonna be talking about the new
Wolfram compiler so and this is a
feature that we introduced in wolfram
version 12 so the outline of this
presentation is I'm going to talk about
the usage and syntax of this new wolfram
compiler then i'm going to talk about
how the compiler is implemented so a
high-level view of the pipeline then
we're going to use the compiler to
leverage pre-existing language features
and also generates in safe code and then
we're going to talk finally we're going
to talk about future developments so the
new compiler so there was an existing
compiler from Mathematica we decided to
start a new compiler and is designed
because it's designed from the ground up
this version to be seamlessly
interfacing
the rest of the Wolfram language in fact
the compiler is written in the Wolfram
language it's accessible so that users
can add new functions or new types so
extending the compiler by developing
libraries or data structures and the
idea is that we're going to continuously
upgrade and develop this compiler for
further so this is a long-term project
we're just previewing it in version 12
right so the syntax of this new compiler
is you have a function compile option
and that takes a function and if you
evaluate that then what you're going to
get as output is a compiled code
function that then you can evaluate now
the structure is that you have your
function and you're going to define
types on the input arguments so for
example in this case I'm going to talk
about I'm gonna define R I'm gonna say
that arguin has a type of integer 64 and
arg2 has an integer 64 as well now note
that the intermediate operations so you
don't need to define the types of
there's a sophisticated type inference
mechanism which will deduce that the
Plus that here means it's an in integer
addition now why did we develop the new
compiler well the old compiler has been
introduced
like since version 2 so that's more than
20 years ago and it wasn't accessible so
you couldn't do certain operations so in
this in this new compiler we extended
the support of the number of
mathematical constructs or rule from
language constructs that you're able to
express and it plays nicely between the
you know so it's a in in languages you
have usually compiled code that's you
know highly you want it to be highly
performed code and you have some sort of
visualization or some data filtering
code that doesn't really require to be
as performance so that with the compiler
you can have a marriage between the two
so in this case I'm completing the
Mandelbrot set and mental process is
very computationally expensive but I'm
leveraging the existing tool like
density plot to plot the results which
is not as computationally expensive and
with this new compiler you can express
things that the old compiler was not
able to do so for example recursive
functions so in this case I'm defining a
factorial function so I have a fact fun
which if the argument if the input is 1
then I'm going to return 1 otherwise I'm
going to multiply that argument by
recursively calling this fat phone with
Arde minus 1 and if I call that then I
can call this function and note that
it's the same as if you would have
called the factorial function it would
in regular Mathematica and another
feature is that you can compose these
functions so and again a limitation of
the old compiler is that you weren't
able to quite compose your functions but
in this case you can so let's say I want
to do a bisection route-finding method
so I can define a function generically
that takes any function that has a
signature of a real goes to real so
things like sine or cosine or tangent
and it's going to take a you know
starting position and ending position
and this this function is generic it's
just taking another function as input so
let's say I want to say the input
function is a sine function so then I
can do the you know compile that sine
function and then I can pass that into
the compiled expression now the
composite pipeline follows a traditional
compilation pattern where you have a
Wolfram language ASD that then we
transform it to ad shugart form so a
more primitive AST so things like you
know table and and and
app might get reduced to something a bit
different then we generate some
intermediate representation so this is
very close to somebody it's not exactly
assembly but it's a machine independent
assembly language then we do a type
inference on that and then we create the
type version of this intermediate
representation and then we generate
executables so this is you know talking
about the same thing
notice that we leverage some
pre-existing and quite popular tools
like you know the LOV Mir although we're
not typed into the LLVM are we're
generating you know that the default is
to generate lv Mir and we can generate
JIT code so just in time compilation or
do ahead of time compilation by
generating libraries and we can target
other backends like JavaScript C++ on
the Wolfram language and we're exploring
those for future releases so the
structure of the compiler is it does the
transformation in terms of what we call
passes so it's a pipeline mechanism and
in this case you know you have a Wolfram
language then you're gonna create some
expression you're gonna do some analysis
and there's a lot of these analysis that
you know you could invoke now all this
is hidden behind the scenes for you but
you can also invoke them directly if if
you so choose so there's about you know
there's a few hundred of those sort of
passes and these are optimizations or
transformations that you you need to do
now what can you do if you have a
composite function well one thing you
could do is you can save it so the idea
is that you know you don't need to go
through this compilation mechanism every
time you want to use the function so you
can save the output in terms of assembly
so this is machine code you know x86
assembly is a monomer on a x86 system or
you can generate LLVM I are so LLVM has
its own intermediate representation
and this is the sort of another
representation or what might be more
useful is you could generate a library
so in this case I'm you know I have a
function which adds one I'm going to
generate the library then it can
essentially say library function loads
and that's going to load that vibrating
to my current session so these two could
be in multiple colonel sessions so let's
say you know compiled a library and then
I can send it to a bunch of systems you
know using you know the cloud or not in
the cloud the grid Mathematica and then
I can load these in each one of these
sub kernels I can load the function and
then they can do the evaluation and you
can also generate code for exotica
architectures like for example web
assembly or CUDA you can generate code
for those as well now we don't have tie
in tight integration with those sort of
exotic systems but we're actually have
prototypes for example integrating with
web assembly or CUDA but and those will
be introduced in potentially future
versions now I'm not one one of the
questions is what systems are what
symbols are supported or which functions
are supported and there is quite a few
functions that are supported mostly
centered are on numerix but you can
extend those as well and there's many
more internal simple you know system
sort of that we support so the compiler
is built on top of Mathematica and in
these some more primitive functions to
do some of these operations right so to
if tie that into the first session let's
say I want to do an external evaluate so
I have a function that is in Python but
I want to call it from within my
compiled code so as Todd showed you
could you use the external evaluate to
evaluate two plus two in Python and you
get four great so now I'm going to build
a function which takes two arguments and
it's going to use a string template to
construct a Python program that adds
these two arguments together so this is
a regular mathematical function if I
pass in 20 and 30 I'm gonna get 50 but
now I want to call this from within you
know my compiled code so let's say I
have a very complicated code but I need
to use some Python library or some
external functionality or maybe the
unity engine to do the evaluation so
that's where there's a function called
kernel function where you just annotate
the types of the input and you can call
these functions from within the compiled
code so python is the this sort of
function that we defined which does the
external evaluation and I can you know
it evaluate this in Python so from
within compiled code so this kind of is
important because there are some
functions that are inherently in
Mathematica and the Wolfram language
that you that are hard or impossible to
compile now you can also kind of go to
the flip side so there there's a lot of
algorithms that require some constant
data as a seed to do the computation so
for example we want to do primarily
testing and for that you need to get the
first few Prime's from you know as a
seat so these are you traditionally
specify this constants if you write this
code in in in C or C++ but we can
leverage the Wolfram language to
essentially get these constants
programmatically so this
this this code essentially injects some
variables into the program and it's
going to compute the crime you know
whether a number is prime or not using
some primary testing algorithm so in
this case if I do the evaluation I get a
compile function and then I can check if
is seventeen Prime right the other thing
is you could integrate with other sort
of system like dynamics so here I have a
function that computes the game of life
board you know set up at a single
iteration and then I can generate an
initial board configuration and then I
can dynamically plot the results using
array plot and dynamic another sort of
interesting thing is that you can
compose bigger you know you can write
bigger code so for example in this case
I have a a quick search function which
takes a packed array or a list of
Machine integers of Rank 1 so it's a
vector of integers and performs
quicksort now I can then essentially
perform the quicksort so I get some I'm
going to generate some random integers
between minus 100 and 100 so I'm going
to generate 20 of those and I am I can
sort them now it is kind of neat to look
at you know does it work for larger
inputs and the answer is obviously yes
now there's a lot of documentation on
the documentation page about how to use
function compiled and there's a lot of
knobs and switches that you can use to
configure your tweak your compilation
so the Wolfram compiler in summary is a
new execution path for the Wolfram
language it uses innovative and
important programming technologies and
it allows you to you know allows you to
have a path towards compiling your code
so you don't have to compile your entire
code you can have some kernel functions
you know spreading out in the code and
but you can have a larger parts in the
compiled code it supports a lot of
variety of types so Atomics like strings
you know you know lists containers data
arrays and and things like that function
functions it has support for the Wolfram
language so you can call Wolfram
languages from within the compiler or
vice versa you can have a lot of
different output targets and you know
for example you could do ahead of time
compilation so you can compile and ship
libraries to users it has this callback
to the Wolfram evaluator and it you know
it's a he uses the LLVM to generate
machine executable code and it's a this
is a typical design for the compiler and
it's released in Wolfram it's released
in wolfram version 12 and we're
constantly updating it and we plan on
essentially providing updates every few
months as new developments and new
compilers get released so so in future
developments we want to make the
compilation faster so that's a big
curdling Blokland we've made it quite
faster in version 12 but we're
constantly we want to make it much much
faster and for that we want to compile
the compiler so that's a big test for us
is can we compile the compiler which is
itself as written in the Wolfram
language we want to add more ability for
users to define types and have proper
standalone support and we want to
support other sort of exotic platforms
like CUDA and web assembly
and we're gonna want to leverage these
compiler methodologies to allow users to
you know have better things like editor
support or linting or analysis so that
would be you know helping the programmer
you know write functions or how to do
computation or provide syntax warning or
partial evaluation and code generation
so with that I'm going to give it to
Christian who's going to talk about
blockchain right so thank you for
joining today on Christian Pascal going
to give you the manager at Wolfram
research of America and today I'm going
to make a quick overview of our new
blockchain functionality and basically
talk about how to read and write data to
you to blog chains and so actually not
all all these functions are new but we
added more support to them so let's
start first about blocking data so this
function returns general information
about the network and winter days with
in 11 3 we only supported bid coming and
appearing but now we not only support
maintenance
but we also support the deference which
is super useful when you are
I'm trying to experiment with all these
functions and to learn from from this
blog team so for example here you can
see and let me show you these as a
dataset you can however be of what we
cut here the properties so you see here
we have been mainly data different for
each of watching and none of them have a
specific properties for them so one of
the things we always try to do needs but
only to return data but also to return
computable data so like in this case for
example I'm going to take this quantity
here so as you see the full form you see
the quantity has Association gates and I
can start doing computation with this
like I can convergence key say US
dollars or to a more added to more
exotic currency like so in solid real
oil to support cryptocurrencies so if I
want to convert me to let's say ripple
Network um alright so yeah this is get a
general information about the network so
what about blocks so let's talk about
the blood teamwork beta function so this
function here returns information about
the specific block so the first argument
is the block hider hash in this case I
use minus 1 I'm going to get the latest
block after block teams and something I
didn't mention before I should mention
here is that the blockchain babe option
is the one you use to specify there's
Washington one to directly so in this
case you can see in from
Meishan about the visa specific block
and
I'm going to extract one
one particular property so let's say the
byte count so if I can be basically the
size of the cock-block invites so we'll
track this from the lick minute and
we'll do the same thing from from the
Bitcoin that's it and from here I can do
anything I want to like I can fill out
the bar chart to compare these this
blocks or
basically anything I wanted that
information so let's do something
interesting that I think it's super
useful when you want to use all these
local language power from other systems
so
let's talk about a/b ice so I went I'm
going to first grade a very simple
function which called these block size
and my function will return
my function returns the size of this
blog let's just use the Bitcoin magnet
here I don't I'm not only want a number
let's say I'm going to return a string
and say here something like on the size
of the blog we leave the - and here -
all right so
I try these we add enough well one two
three four five six I get the result if
I try with another one I get it so this
is this is fine working from the open
language but what about if I want if you
work from an Earthling so we have this
very powerful function if a function and
that allows me to create instant api's
so I'm going to create one API that
receives one parameter called blocks
went to be an integer and what I'm going
to do with this is I'm going to return
the output of the function I just wrote
here
like this and
I'm going to deploy this to our cloud
what's called its API test and set the
permissions public
I now have an API so let's say if I go
to my terminal here and I curl B
API and they provide
very what's called blog so let's try
again one two three four five six and I
should I should get the result here
again I can try with out of luck and so
I can do the same theme from any other
language that's boards make it to be
requested to be Python or C or any other
language alright so we
blobs and what about transactions we
have the watching transaction data
function so the function is very useful
to inspect transaction details and we'll
try to return
all kind of information about
transactions so remember I mentioned
before here the blocking based option
so let I'm going to stick to the Bitcoin
Testament I going to do some experiments
here so I also have the variable dollar
blocking base and if I said this to you
in this case for example bit contestant
this will set the default value for the
bottom base option so I don't have to
use these
option and anymore so remember we had
this block here so it's up to 16 [ __ ]
right so from here I want to extract the
transaction list
so there's actually
it is multifaceted three
Oh
Oh
actions included in his blog what's mine
so I'm going to window behind a
transaction a random choice a page let's
call this one intersection all right
remember this is from the mainland so
for now for my experiment I just want to
show you this using Bitcoin and you can
see here again a lot of information
about the about the transaction so one
new thing we have here is the
provide now
a lot more more information we get a
victim for example at inputs and the
outputs here you can see the complete
script so for example you can see a
standard eight about key cash script you
can see the the unlocking script to the
case and more information that can be
very useful
all right so
um so I wanted to do a I did something
some some months ago I encoded data in
in the Bitcoin Testament so I have that
transaction ID image here and let's see
I don't remember what I did is at let's
find out all right so the transaction is
from Avery and what I actually want from
here are the outputs so
remember I was showing you how we
provide a lot of information from from
the outputs sometimes you extract the
I want the outputs of the transaction
and you probably don't don't see
anything weird right now but let's um if
I trust get the amounts
sorry okay
if I have here over mounds
this is where encoded the data this one
is the change - back to myself so I'm
going to remove this and I'm going to
say P such announced ok and
I'm going to play with these data I just
got from the front of Arkansas
so as you can see here you have without
quantities are with bitcoins at units
but I don't want the unit's right now I
just want the bandages so I'm going to
just extract the magnitude and I want
this in a big digital form so that we
multiplied needs right and rounded or so
right I'm finally going to get the
injured digits in base two
you
all right and I'm going to say these
digits
and finally
I want to normalize the G for all these
one material to have the same length
so I already have a code to do that so
you may be wondering what's in here so
if I execute an array plot fold this you
will find something I hope you are
familiar with and not let me show you
what this so if I run 15 steps of rule
110 you see that I encoded these still
are some atoms in the UM the contestants
let's actually compare these two results
yes they are the same all right so
how did I go to leave that
talk about writing data to to the
blockchain so before we talk we talk
about it
oh by the way if it wasn't clear enough
I'm getting one question from the
audience so this function here is
visually from here it's basically
willing to doing something like a girl
execute that is going to fetch the UL I
provided here all right so before we
talk about writing data something very
relevant to launching is therapy so we
are interesting the authority tools in
version 12 we already had some but now
we support elliptic curves so I'm going
to generate a pair of private and public
keys using a little bit slippage curve
like this and I'm going to use something
really cool so we have now the block
kinky and code function that can use a
privateer of wtg return different things
so in this case what I want is I want to
encode these public key at Sandra's and
I can do this with
different launching societies with
Bitcoin you'll see caster on the form of
a beacon address on maintenance I can do
the same thing we expected but for this
particular example I want to do this
with the fear investment so let's call
these my address
and soul it
try to experiment here sign Kappa
I have a deer impossibly fidgety
battements awesome so I'm going to send
I got to some some ether to give to the
advice ideas created here all right so
let's
depending so we can actually check that
from here
so I also have the blog tuning address
data function that will return
information about these visitors
oops happiness that you care doesn't
okay ah it's inside we see the
yeah it's been mine alright so I have
now differing these account Satyricon
that I've created and now I'm going to
do I'm going to create a new pair of
keys so they generate two keeper also if
you go to our documentation our methods
are the amended here this case elliptic
curve we support is the one useful
between Imperium but we are working on
to add more motors right so let's create
another pair of keys and
are going to use
Michael here but in this case going to
be the coldest destination there is I'm
going to use the public key here to
encode a new address on the shared
business alright and now once you if we
check these
address here with the with logical data
you should be empty yeah it says so I'm
going to create a lodging transaction
and send some ether from this account to
this account
I don't have to I don't have to memorize
the whole thing we have everything
recommended and we try to add common
examples here so I can so I can use this
one and so this is a symbolic
representation of the transaction so
let's call this transaction
hi miss Kate another instruction down in
here oh it's fine gas price I'm going to
send it to the destination bridge and
genomic sequence
I mean half a liter all right so I'll
attend visit yes a representation of up
there and such and happen being
sensitive to the beaten to the luncheon
yet so the first thing I come to do is I
need to sign my transaction the same
thing is probably for for victims well
the form is different as you can see as
you can see here it is a different
infection and limited material
construction and we're working on
supporting more block chains so each
section will have its own
[Music]
the difficulties alright so let's let's
sign this transaction so I have a
blockchain transaction sign function
that will sign the new transaction we
remember I've had these circuits so I'm
going to use the private key from here
and as you can see the object the block
intersection project changes it now has
the D icon different and proper design B
is true it is still not in the
blockchain so for that I can t do to
block intersection submit function
[Music]
you send me to to the queue blocking
educate the the object has the
information about the love gentle I
don't need to certify that it is for the
between definite because it's already
here so alright so let's try to do this
and the intent to to the blockchain and
if I get a transaction maybe let's call
this new transaction ID and I can do
something like blockchain transaction
data and see if it has been mined on
okay
I probably chief specified watching
basic peer assessment
you
what which is has been mine so let's see
the so remember we have a VP address
with your balance so if I run this again
let's try it
here
so I should did yep y-you have some
money down here
all right so
we are also we always working on adding
more
[Music]
more blockchains more support to
luncheon functionalities so it it will
be very useful also to get feedback from
you in the bowls and to comment to the
questions to see what kind of things you
would like to see from
blockchains the writer with an open
language
so I'm reaching some questions here
about beacon price so we use different
speeds together
maybe comprise and and about brainwallet
Kings so with
currently support us generating keys in
the way I showed here that we are
working on adding more support to
different specialties and ways to create
keys and eventually wallets and more
things so yes that's all for now on you
work very much and I hope you use all
these and it's helpful for you thank you